all right we're going to begin this hour
with an investigation into the
kidnapping of a Florida woman back in
2017. Alyssa matthewson was woken up by
her estranged husband who claimed that
he wanted to reconcile with her well
investigators say that estranged husband
Trevor Summers climbed into her home
through a window then kidnapped
assaulted and nearly killed her Peter
Van Sant spoke with matthewson in a
wide-ranging interview for 48 hours
here's an early look at his report
my dad had sat me down and discussed
reconciling with my mom and fixing the
marriage Arden Summers was eager to help
her dad Trevor talk to her mother Alisa
about making their family whole again so
when her dad asked Arden to leave a
window open at her mother's house she
agreed even though a court had ordered
him to stay away I would let my dad in
the window after my siblings and my mom
went to bed but Trevor Summers supposed
attempt at reconciliation was actually
an act of manipulation using the
children as pawns it was a plot that
would involve kidnapping assault and
attempted murder tormenting Elisa for 55
hours starting with when he entered her
bedroom I just start in full Panic
throwing things from my end table at him
this must be terrifying it's terrifying
I am here with Elisa at her house
I'm not supposed to be and I woke Elise
up and I have been holding her against
trouble
Trevor Summers made a video confessing
to some of his actions by then he had
sent their children away telling Arden
then just 14 years old and who had no
real Driving Experience to drive her
siblings to his house and wait meanwhile
elise's torment continued he put a
pillow over my face and I thought about
my kids and I lost consciousness
and Peter Van Sant joins us now boy
Peter the idea of preying on a kid's
natural hope that their parents are
going to get back together it's evil
it's really is that's exactly what it is
what happened at trial well if there
isn't enough drama in this story already
so at trial Elisa is questioned by the
prosecutor when he finishes uh asking
questions her husband stands up and he
says I'm firing my attorney and I am now
going to represent myself
so I've never seen this before and
there's a camera in the courtroom so you
can watch this unfold wow so he stands
up and he cross-examines his own wife
the woman that he had tortured
physically mentally tied up for 55 hours
and he's also allowed to cross-examine
two of his children wow it's an
extraordinary scene but Elisa who's just
a remarkable character She lays him out
in that courtroom it's a very dramatic I
think about the trauma of the children I
do think it's evil that you're going to
use your own children imagine how that
daughter feels thinking she's helping
her dad knowing what he ultimately did I
had no idea what she was exactly right
and there's video of her that night it's
one o'clock in the morning she's going
down this darkened sidewalk to her
mother's house all excited that I'm
going to let Dad in and they're going to
reconcile we'll be a family again when
in fact she was being used used in the
most horrible of ways what is wrong with
Trevor Summers then I mean what was it
what was his end goal he intended did he
intend to kill his wife what was he well
she believes so he he later said no I
still wanted to reconcile which is
ridiculous but he wrote a confession and
also a note to his children when he was
during the 55 hours there in that car
and one of the things he wrote to them
is that Mom and Dad will be looking down
at you from Heaven oh my gosh so Elisa
says that's true suicide potential
murder suicide he claimed he had
offshore accounts and he told her during
this this hostage time that he was going
to flee overseas by boat but that was
all ridiculous wow well she made it out
okay she did Escape we'll have to you
have to tune in I think uh to see that
extraordinary story intervention thank
you very much and you can see Peter's
full report Alicia mathewson's night
terrors on 48 hours tomorrow night at 10
9 Central here on CBS and of course on
Paramount Plus